Elisabeth borne qui reçoit aujourd'hui à
Matignon à sa défile depuis ce matin et
ça va durer encore jusqu'à demain elle
reçoit les présidents de groupe
parlementaires sur la table évidemment
la réforme des retraites quel que soit
le moyen employé législatif et
évidemment démocratique c'est-à-dire
dans le dialogue dans la discussion en
échangeant avec tout le monde et sans
marcher sur des pieds de qui que ce soit
nous ayons allaité prochain une réforme
des retraites qui entre en vigueur et là
l'impression qu'on a c'est qu'on veut
nous faire acheter un âne dans un sac
c'est-à-dire on sait pas on sait pas on
sait pas comment les la question des
retraites va être traitée donc la homard
en l'occurrence pour un camion c'est
retourner Babette déversant sa cargaison
sur le bitume des sextoys des centaines
de sextoys recouvrant la route certains
de nos confrères américains ont enquêté
analysé la cargaison il s'agit du modèle
10 potes touch finger vibretter dans une
déclaration enregistrée hier mais
diffusée ce matin dans tout le pays
Vladimir Poutine franchi un nouveau cap
dans la guerre qu'il mène à l'Ukraine
protégez notre patrie sa souveraineté et
son intégrité territoriale pour assurer
la sécurité de notre peuple j'estime
nécessaire de procéder à une
mobilisation partielle la mobilisation
une première depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale à la télévision c'est son
ministre de la Défense qui en a précisé
les contours son concernés les hommes de
18 à 65 ans ayant une expérience
militaire ou du combat ce à quoi nous
assistons depuis le 24 février dernier
est un retour à l'âge des impérialismes
et des Colonies il s'agit d'une mauvaise
décision de la part de la Russie nous
allons bien sûr en discuter et nous
concerter sur le plan politique pour
savoir comment réagir l'objectif de
l'Occident est de détruire la Russie et
maintenant il y a beaucoup de sujets qui
nous opposent ils ont notamment financé
des terroristes dans le Caucase ils ont
créé la russophobie la guerre commençait
en 2014 c'est la faute de l'Occident la
Russie
à 17 ressenti menacé mais personne à
menacer la Russie et personne d'autre
que la Russie n'a cherché le conflit ce
qui se taisent aujourd'hui servent
malgré eux ou secrètement avec une
certaine complicité la cause d'un nouvel
impérialisme d'un cynisme contemporain
qui désagrège notre ordre international
je tiens à vous rappeler que notre pays
dispose également de diverses armes de
destruction et à certains égards elles
sont même plus modernes que celles des
pays de l'OTAN pour protéger la Russie
et notre peuple nous utiliserons
certainement tous les moyens à notre
disposition ce n'est pas du bluff je ne
crois pas qu'il va utiliser les armes
nucléaires je vais vous le dire très
clairement je ne crois pas que le monde
va le laisser faire ne le faites pas ne
le faites pas ne le faites pas
vous allez changer le visage de la
guerre comme jamais depuis la Seconde
Guerre mondiale vous pourriez faire un
buzz en incitant un bombarder
Moscou ah bah non je vais pas le faire
aujourd'hui c'est une plaisanterie
évidemment merci beaucoup
entre la Russie et les États-Unis
notamment que la fusée Soyouz a décollé
depuis le Kazakhstan direction de la
station spatiale internationale à son
bord de cosmonautes russes et un
astronaute américain un décollage en
commun qui pourrait être l'un des
derniers la Russie annonçait sa volonté
de quitter l'ISS après 2024 pour créer
sa propre station orbitale ce n'est pas
aux partis politiques à des commissions
qui sont organisées par des gens
généralement proches des uns et des
autres puisque tout le monde se connaît
de se faire justice et d'ailleurs ce qui
est très gras c'est la dissimulation de
la France insoumise aucun d'entre nous
ne s'est exprimé dans la direction de
demander à Adrien cadenas de renoncer à
son mandat de député et donc nous le
ferons pas et c'est la raison pour
laquelle maintenant nous souhaitons nous
projeter dans les batailles qui viennent
je suis pas là pour accabler un parti
politique pour faire la leçon de morale
parce que je pense qu'aucun parti n'a le
monopole du vise et aucun monopole de la
vertu voilà c'est votre partie également
j'en viens à Sandrine Rousseau la lutte
contre les ventes faites aux femmes
c'est pas le baltrap voilà c'est pas le
ball-trap politique c'est pas tous les
jours on en flingué